[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay new idea we children voices harmony
mustaches today we're joining a
barbershop quartet for one day I was
formally trained when I was growing up I
sang in choirs for six years I did
musical theater growing up but mostly I
just like to sing in the car yeah you
should take chorus in high school and
then when I'm drunk
I will sing karaoke I have no formal
seating experience at all I tried to get
in the choir and they wouldn't let me do
it mister go to hell I think it's gonna
be extremely difficult to form a
barbershop quartet in one day especially
because I feel like I'm gonna be the
weak link in this group I love to sing
I'm not great with rhythm I cannot read
music again mr. godell I think once we
get the sound once we know what our
parts are when we come together as a
group it'll come together really really
well I'm Joey
I'm Jackson I'm Jake
so barbershop harmony is it's for people
singing together to be all guys to be
all girls to be a mix and it's tight
close harmonies so we're gonna need to
know your notes we're gonna be learning
a very old classic barbershop tune
called by the light of the silvery moon
and you're gonna be singing it and it's
too late to quit so the four different
parts in barbershop from the top down we
go tenor lead baritone and bass so we
got our babies hello I'm bass all right
we have our lead I'm lead we have
and our tenor yep all right let's do
this guy's fine all right
[Music]
[Applause]
we're gonna jump right into this this is
gonna be super super easy okay I keep
saying oh shoot I need a [ __ ]
if the tenor doesn't know their part
whole thing Falls we could do it without
the tenor I want you to try as far as
you can without the music in front of
you huh we say lots of spoon again call
that an echo by the silvery by the light
by the light of the silvery oh wait I
say moon by the light of the silvery
[Music]
[Applause]
hello everyone how we doing today please
welcome the Buzzcocks
[Applause]
[Music]
I want to sue
- my honey - honey
keep it shining in juvey behind you your
silvery beams will bring love streams
will be kind of in soon will be coming
soon by the silvery white a silvery moon
my the silver
by the silvery by the silvery
thereby the
[Music]
we finished it we did it I thought we
did really well better than I would've
expected I think we did the best we
could in a day for people who don't who
are like good at this but I feel like
it's such a specific art form I don't
think I did a good job
it was fun yeah just be able to be in
front of our co-workers try something
here we haven't done before
yeah if I see you in the hall like you
might have a little karaoke but walk in
the hall and hit a yeah we did oh yeah
[Music]
[Music]